hey guys in this video i'm gonna show
you five interesting things that happens
to your body while you are sleeping
this video is gonna change the way you
think about the importance of good
quality sleep for the rest of your life
let's get to it
[Music]
your immune system puts on the nitrous
while you're sleeping your body is
boosting your immune system because
while you are in dreamland your body is
busy fighting off infections
according to insider.com people who
consistently sleep poorly or don't get
enough sleep are more prone to illness
and infection now you know why you
always feel so sleepy when you're ill
because your body is telling you go to
sleep because i want to go to war and
bring you back to health
your body makes more hormones especially
the hormone called melatonin which is
crucial for good quality sleep and then
while you're asleep cortisol which is
the main stress hormone that just drops
so basically your body is making more of
certain hormones and less of others just
so you can function normally while you
are sleeping and also then when you wake
up
now if you don't sleep enough you can be
out of balance
your hormones will be kind of messed up
for example the levels of your hormones
that control hunger
leptin and ghrelin will change how much
you want to eat
often resulting in weight gain
your skin repairs itself according to
insider.com many skin cells have
circadian clocks and are directly
affected by the amount of sleep we
receive each night maintaining a regular
sleep schedule can keep our skin healthy
being sleep deprived can contribute to
skin conditions like psoriasis
acne
and rosacea so if you want to have bad
skin continue to stay up late
playing games and then just have bad
skin
the brain comes down when you go to
sleep when you fall into sleep and you
sleep normally
you go into non-rem sleep rem stands for
rapid eye movement
when you go to sleep into non-rem sleep
your brain comes down and it goes into
this kind of rhythmic pattern peaceful
but according to webmd when you start to
dream your brain cells fire actively and
randomly in fact in rem sleep brain
activity looks similar to when you are
awake
now just before we go to number five if
you like the video so far chances are
you like the rest of my channel as well
so remember to subscribe and also click
that notification bell so you won't miss
any of the future videos i would really
love the support now let's go to the
next one
[Music]
your muscles go into a paralyzed mode
like this your body is kind of forcing
your muscles to shut down let me explain
it this way when you move right your
brain uses the prefrontal cortex to
create to control motor right your body
movement so it's kind of shutting your
muscles down so that you are not
dangerous to your wife who is sleeping
next to you because you can hurt if your
body is just going crazy so during rem
sleep your prefrontal cortex is kind of
just shut down then later the brain stem
then talks to the hepatologist to just
wake you up again so you can start your
day
if you're struggling to sleep and if you
want tips to have good quality sleep
then check out this video here and i'll
see you there and always remember
life is short so don't waste yours
cheers guys